To get started running unit
tests with the Java plugin,
all you need to do is place your
tasks in the source test Java folder.
You can, of course,
change the location of your test code
by configuring the test source set.
The only thing we have to manually
configure is our test dependencies.
In this example, we're using JUnit
as our testing framework, so
we have to add a JUnit dependency
to the test compile configuration.
Running our test is easy.
Just run the test task.
You'll notice Gradle has to perform
a bunch of other tasks before it
can actually run our tests.
It has to compile our Java source and
then compile our test source, and
finally it can run the tests.
In this case, the build was successful
indicating that all of our tests passed.
Gradle also provides detailed
reports on our test execution.
These reports are placed in
the build reports directory.
Let's take a look at
one of these reports.
In this case, you can see we have one
test and that the test was successful.
Of course in a real project
you'd have many tests.
Now I've gone and
edited our task so it will fail.
Let's see what happens when
we run the test this time.
Oh no, our build failed.
Let's see what went wrong.
Execution failed for task ":test".
There were failing tests.
All right, we expected that.
Let's check out the report.
Looking at the report tells us we
ran one test, and that it failed.
And then we can even
look at our test class
to see the full stacktrace
of what went wrong.